[Music]
it's time for ETS late-night roundup
your quick catch-up on all the best
celebrity scoop after dark how big of a
stoner is Anne Hathaway on 4/20 not a
little one you're not a little thing
here's the thing though I'm a parent and
I don't feel like getting arrested so
I'm gonna say zero okay Anne Hathaway
opened up about her pot smoking habits
on Thursdays watch what happens live
with Andy Cohen she also poked fun at
her now infamous 2013 Oscars speech at
that point I would have been happy to
see any of them up there giving a speech
instead of me Anne was also a guest on
The Late Late Show with James Corden she
totally fangirled over working with
Rihanna on the upcoming ocean's 8 she'd
lean forward and just slay us all with
like the wit and the kindness and the
lovingness and-and-and and I just left
her so Oh
Armie Hammer was also there he revealed
the unique job he had in middle school
selling Playboy magazines and small
bottles of lotion here's what happened
when he got caught and the principal
searched his locker what they didn't
know is that I had a weird feeling
something like this happened so I
stuffed him in a bunch of plastic bags
and tied him up and stuffed him in the
bushes in front of the McDonald's it was
right by our school right so they opened
my locker and there's obviously no
Playboy's in there but there was like a
bunch of little cans of lotion yeah so
they're like what's the lowest rose like
I get dry rages thank you and adorable
over on The Tonight Show with Jimmy
Fallon Robert Irwin made his dad the
late Steve Irwin proud he showed off
some creepy and cuddly creatures
you